[Applause]
at least three people are dead and more
than 270 injured after a truck loaded
with gas exploded and set off an inferno
in Kenya's capital A government
spokesperson says many people were home
late at night when the fire reached
their houses in a Nairobi neighborhood a
flying gas cylinder hit a warehouse
burning it down and other businesses
were damaged as well the death toll is
expected to rise as firefighters
continue to search the a
[Applause]
area oh my God that is my mom screaming
my name sever Phil pH because she
thought that the world was ending and uh
yeah that that's the point where I I ran
back to the car yeah before we knew it
there was a huge ball of fire yeah and
this huge ball of fire was radiating
heat and uh I I can't remember the rest
I just fled and in in in that you know
as I scampered for safety I think I
sprained my my my uncle recover but we
we have programs to help them like food
and food yeah it's quite unfortunate
that as you can see here uh this is a
yard an illegal gas filling yard which
had not been licensed by the uh energ
and petroleum reg Authority you know
that is our it's called
Ira uh but then they continue to operate
in a such a residential area high
density area and it's quite unfortunate
that it has
happened uh just showing how sometimes
we have weak uh you know enforcement
institutions and of course the element
of corruption which has now led to the
death of three of us Kenyans the DCI has
clear instructions from the president to
do whatever it takes and to have the
culprate apprehended and presented
before court of law with a ly of charges
let me take this opportunity to appeal
to the people of Kenya our businessmen
not to put money ahead of humanity and
lives